[Musique]
isaac et à une poignée de kilomètres de
la dominique et de la guadeloupe une
grosse masse nuageuse devrait commencer
à nous concerne et dans les toutes
prochaines heures
bonjour albéric marcellin oui bonjour
vous êtes le président de cette
université populaire et de la prévention
albéric marcellin qu'on est votre combat
pour tout ce qui est prévention des
risques naturels que nous encourons ici
en martinique est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de tout ce qui était mise en
oeuvre pour l'arrivée de ce phénomène
même s'il ne devrait pas rester dans les
annales pour être le cas majeurs ben je
crois que le préfet de la martinique
nous a fait la démonstration quand même
comparativement à d'autres préfèrent
voir le passé d'avoir pris son bâton de
pèlerin et d'avoir mis en place certains
de choses dont je veux pour exemple la
multiplication d'un certain nombre de
réunions à la préfecture
la connexion avec les municipalités la
connexion aussi avec météo france et
puis toutes les informations qui sont
données au public
c'est donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose je crois que les
martiniquais aussi globalement bien
réagi je vais le côté un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé avec cette problématique
de l'eau dans les magasins on y
reviendra
voilà mes joueurs europe précisément ce
qui s'est passé dans les magasins de
vente de matériaux il a je crois quand
même que certains hommes de martin qui
ont compris fall a conforté les
invitations donc nous avons évolué
positivement de reproches à voir lorsque
système cyclonique arrive alors par
contre il nous reste beaucoup quand même
à faire pour cela c'est quand même
quelque chose de mineur
mais si nous avions à connaître ce que
je ne souhaite pas bon ni aux mains ou
un mariage veut dire que bon ça va être
un peu compliqué pour nous donc il faut
que les gens continuent leur progression
dans la préparation de la saison
cyclonique alors revenons sur tout ce
qui est prévention hier en préfecture hi
cette réunion et on a parlé de deux
communes plus précisément le prêcheur
rico rivières on entendu les autorités
en charge de tout ce qui est secours de
110 les deux disent avoir dépêché sur
chacune de ces deux communes une unité
mobile ça va dans le bon sens pour vous
oui ça va d'un bon sens d'autant plus
que nos universités mobile et la
prévention nous avons coordonné un
exercice de simulation séisme et tsunami
dans la nuit c'était le 11 novembre 2000
le 10 novembre ici 2017 en 2016 banc
dont nous avons fait ça pendant deux
heures de temps et là on a vu par
exemple que suez grand ouvert qu'un
désert médical et bien que c'est
éminemment compliqué il suffit que vous
ayez des chutes de blocs ou un
glissement de terrain qu'en hiver est
seul au monde
ça fait quand même réfléchir albecq
personnel parce que dans certaines
communes il est plutôt question de
fermer des casernes pour avoir des
petites zones plus en faire une chanson
communautaire oui absolument
nuno stratégie c'est de mettre une
quinzaine partout royaume deuxièmement
lorsqu on a ça coûte cher
voilà même salle à la sécurité n'a pas
de prix deuxièmement lorsqu'on voit un
peu la configuration la vente unique on
a quand même cinq communes en situation
de désert médical
donc là je pense que pré positionner du
matériel et des hommes et pour mettre en
place un dispositif de secours à la
population ça me paraît plus qu'efficace
alors on a parlé des autorités qui qui
coordonne un peu mieux ces dispositifs
de ce qu'on surnommait arrive côté
population on sait bien que dans notre
petit film martinique le shérif il y à
des secteurs plus particulièrement
touchées par un type de catastrophes
potentielles on peut être affectée par
la houle par un glissement de terrain
par une montée des eaux est ce qu'il
faut d'une micro éducation dans cette
zone ultra localisé est ce qu'on a les
moyens de le faire alors c'est ce que
nous avons essayé de faire au niveau de
l'université pour que la prévention il
ya dix ans nous envoie nous avions un
pièce a appelé ça pendant l'opération
wilayas du pays ibérique en installer au
plus proche des populations comme le
fait un peu la mairie du lamentin
rassembler les citoyens et leur donner
du matériel et puis qui sera
opérationnelle en cas de crise donc ça
c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose quand même concernant
la situation bon je pense que dans
l'éducation de notre population
il faut que les gens comprennent des
choses extrêmement précise voilà un
territoire qui n'a pas connu depuis de
très très très longues années des chutes
de groland de grêle on a eu de la grêle
qui est en national anti au 18 avril
et puis tout récemment nous
une tornade sur l'a10 l'ont donc je veux
dire que ces phénomènes la soie sont des
phénomènes quand même assez
impressionnant et ça nous impose d'être
vigilant h 24 c'est extrêmement
important
même sur le l'arrivée de isaac
on ne sait jamais et c'est pour ça que
j'invite les uns et les autres être
extrêmement vigilant pourquoi parce
qu'il a fait extrêmement chaud dans la
zone ces derniers temps ces dernières
semaines il a par exemple on a un océan
qui est autour de 29 degrés donc ça veut
dire que quand isaac se rapproche des
terres eh bien ça peut arriver qu'ils
prennent de la force et nous pose un
certain nombre de soucis vous estimez
finalement globalement nous sommes pas
rire ce qui concerne le risque
cyclonique mais il ya les autres
non alors il ya un cyclone et cyclones
bon là on est dans la stratégie de
tempêtes etc
mais si cio maria on n'est pas encore
prêt sur le déplacement des populations
regardée aux états unis en ce moment là
avec france on a déplacé un million et
demi de personnes voulaient mettre en
sûreté
messina l'entraidé place est à nous
entendre km londres r oui alors le mot
on a 160 mille personnes qui vivent sur
nos côtes au niveau de la vente unique
et un certain nombre d'entre eux d'un
des habitats précaires
en août on les met à insulter donc ça
c'est là la grande question qui nous
faut absolument traité et puis sur la
question de la vigilance 1 et de la
leyre technique comprend pas que ce soit
alors non rouge new green ou violer
alors tremblé en rouge forte pluie et un
jeune 20 d'accord bon alors vous
comprenez qu'on y perde pas son créateur
c'est un peu compliqué mais en même
temps bon je crois qu'il faut apprendre
par coeur comme on le faisait par
exemple des tables de multiplication de
ce que nous étions plus jeunes pour
notre génération est bien au japon avec
les tifs ans et ce qu'ils font
dès la maternelle là par exemple nous
sommes en situation de rouge forte pluie
qui est annoncée avec l'arrivée de isaac
et bien en rouge normalement ne bouge
pas et bien entre le françois est ici
pour cette émission ce matin j'ai croisé
cent soixante dix huit véhicules dont
les années conté oui absolument et j'ai
compté les marcheurs et oui tous ses
biens services personnes à pied
notamment parmi eux il y avait deux qui
venait leur sport quoi est ce qu'il faut
faire il fait verbaliser je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas nous en rouge est
normalement en rouge je ne bouge pas
alors moi je suis là ici à
vous en termes de contribution à la
mission de service public donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai accepté de faire le
déplacement en rouge
bon mais en même temps je veux dire que
sur le rouge ait encore des gens qui
n'ont pas compte qu'ils avaient
d'ailleurs cela très rapidement les kits
est ce que tous les martiniquais sont
équipés comme on devrait pas encore dans
son corps et ses savoirs parce qu'on
estime que c'est de l'argent foutu en
l'air
je ne sais pas mais en même temps bon je
crois que les gens n'ont pas encore pris
la dimension de l'exposition de la
martinique a beaucoup de risques majeurs
alors nous on a pris la décision de
solliciter une entrevue avec monsieur
macro à l'occasion de sa venue ici à
vente-unique dans les prochains jours
parce que nous considérons que s'il
existe un plan séisme antilles qui a été
chiffré par le gouvernement français à 5
milliards d'euros
il nous faut absolument aujourd'hui
mettre en place un plan ouragan majeur
antilles et voir comment est ce que la
vente unique la guadeloupe la dominique
la guadeloupe la martinique saint martin
saint barthélémy et la réunion qui sont
les territoires français les plus
exposés aux risques cycloniques et bien
et les moyens budgétaires par exemple de
mettre les populations en sûreté avant
pendant et après un cyclone puissant les
mairies savez on a fait parler de ce
fameux téléphone satellitaire toutes les
mairies sont équipés alors toutes les
mairies sont équipés depuis dinin de
cela c'est une avancée mais il est
aujourd'hui une problématique avec les
téléphones satellitaires sa porte bien
son nom satellite et sur la gestion des
satellites dans la zone cinglée là ce
sont les américains qui donne les
autorisations donc là ça devient petit
peu compliqué c'est pour ça que nous on
fait une petite pirouette pour aller
vers les radioamateurs les 6 bis parce
que ça on pense que toutes les communes
de vente unique devrait passer une
convention avec l'association des radios
amateurs pour leur permettre de voir
communiquer aussi bien vrai que les
préfectures les sous-préfectures que
l'extérieur de la valentine et une
dernière question albéric marcellin dans
quelques jours emmanuel macron le
président de la république se rendra
dans notre zone
non après le passage de dire mari de
mariah a sur saint martin vous pensez
qu'il faut absolument interpellé tenir
le président de la république par le col
et plus dire il y a quelque chose à
faire je ne sais pas s'ils vont le tenir
voire le coller mais ce que je sais
c'est que nous avions sollicité une
entrevue avec nicolas hulot donc avec
quatre sénateurs qui avaient accueilli
et notre demande
lorsqu'il est venu ici sur la question
des sargasses il ne nous avons reçu mais
il faut que le président de la
république accepte de nous recevoir
parce qu'on a des choses à lui dire
notamment le plan ou adam majeur anti
l'on ne peut pas faire l'économie de
cette affaire-là et il faut que les
politiques aussi nous soutiennent parce
que un jeu on aura des moments
extrêmement difficiles à passer avec un
ouragan majeur sur le territoire de la
martinique donc il faut que le président
de la république accepte que la société
civile lui fasse des propositions et à
ce titre je suis missionné par le
conseil économique et social de vente
unique donc le csm pour élaborer la
nomenclature d'un plan sur les organes
majeurs auxquels nous sommes exposés ici
en martinique merci albéric marcellin
rappel c'est moi qui vous remercie
président de l'université populaire et
de la prévention merci d'avoir été ce
matin dans son crédit un peu
exceptionnel merci bonne journée
[Musique]